American Psycho might have seemed like a
straightforward film about a psychotic
serial killer one who has good hygiene
and the noses fun types but the third
act of the movie intentionally in
raffles and leaves us guessing about
what if anything actually happens to our
deranged protagonists throughout the
whole film see that's the trouble with
having a delusional maniac at the center
of the plot his memory of his own
supposed murder spree might not be so
reliable after all
like any good film however there are an
abundance of clues scattered throughout
the movie and subsequent commentaries
might help fans parse out Patrick
Bateman's reality from his mental
fiction so let's take a look at what
really happens at the end of American
Psycho the body count there's one
surefire fact that we can all agree upon
when it comes to Patrick Bateman the guy
is crazy whether he actually kills all
the people he thinks he does is up for
debate but his status as a lunatic is
not from his obsessive compulsive
fitness and grooming regimens to his
fixation with card stock and music
history
he's clearly disturbed but has he
actually killed all those people or is
he just imagining it's all as some sorts
of sick fetish fun to say part of me
wants to take her out and talk to her be
real nice and sweet and treat her right
and what the other part of him think
putter head would look like on a stick
some believe he's just dreaming up all
those intense slaughter sessions and
that there's some serious evidence to
back that idea up consider that time as
ATM tells him to feed a stray cats
before he shoots a walk along witness
for interfering at least some parts of
that experience as a hallucination and
the fact that he then engages in a
shootout with police that culminates in
him blowing up their cruiser with just
his Glock with some outlandish even he
doesn't believe it's real and isn't it a
little suspicious of a guy who can
rattle off every shade of ink known to
man and recite an entire encyclopedia on
Phil Collins as somehow can't recall his
own kill counts I guess I've killed
maybe 20 people maybe 40 let's just say
that Bateman takes a concept of the
unreliable narrator to a whole new level
however the convenient alibi the biggest
mystery in the film revolves around the
whether or not a Patrick Bateman
actually ever killed his coworker Paul
Allen played by Jared Leto
Paul's deaf scene would prove to be one
of the most memorable moments of the
movie and forever change our viewers
experienced Huey Lewis and the news
music Patrick is subsequently given an
extremely convenient alibi by the
detective investigating Paul's
disappearance that may or may not be the
real deal before the murder
Patrick is shown going to dinner with
Paul under the name marcus halberstram
another co-worker Paul has long a
mistaken Patrick for but when questioned
the real Marcus reveals he was at
another location the night of the murder
with Patrick Bateman himself enlisted as
part of that group so either Patrick has
actually gone to the dinner with Marcus
and his other pals while dreaming up his
deadly encounter with Paul or he's done
exactly what he thinks he has and his
colleagues mistakenly gift him an alibi
considering how often all those Pierson
appears vice-presidents seem to call
each other by the wrong names with a
narrative definitely seems to be leaning
towards the latter the cover up one of
the main reasons were left to wonder if
any of these murders are real is that
every shred of evidence that might
convict him disappears overnight at the
tail end of his murderous rampage
Patrick has turned Paul swanky apartment
into a mini graveyard for his victims
bodies but when he returns to the scene
of the crime at the place is completely
clean it appears that the property
owners have removed or traces of
wrongdoing and painted over the blood
filled closet to ensure the ritzy
locales high rental value and the
listing agents attitude toward him
certainly betrays some suspicion I want
to know what happened there don't make
any trouble please
I suggest you go then there's the matter
of his lawyer whom he'd feverishly
confessed to via voicemail at first
Herald cons literally laughs of his
message calls him by the name Davis and
says Patrick Bateman is a sorry subject
choice for such a joke because he's too
dorky to actually commit murder that was
you wasn't it you know natural Bateman
killing Alan in the escort girls that's
fabulous that's rich
but then when Patrick makes it clear
he's not joking his attorney claims that
there's no way he could have killed bull
Alan because I had dinner with Paul Alan
twice in London just ten days ago no you
could this man who was caught his own
client by the wrong name twice of simply
mistaken Paul Alan was someone else too
sure which is why it takes an
explanation from on high to really
understand what was meant by these
ambiguous scenes let's hear from the
folks who made this thing the voice of
authority director mary harron has since
revealed that she never intended for
audiences to believe patrick was
innocent everyone keep coming out of
this film thinking that it's all a dream
and I never intended it she went on to
explain that the last scene wasn't meant
to make it seem like Patrick Bateman
can't separate his imagination from
reality but rather that cons on the rest
are the ones who have really confused
not everything was real of course
screenwriter Guinevere Turner has said
that the turning point in Patrick's
psychosis takes place when he gets
absorbed in his own reflection while
sleeping with two prostitutes she told
Yahoo movies in real life they probably
weren't as attractive as they are and it
wasn't all those penthouse letters as it
is in other words Patrick Bateman might
have embellished a few of the more
outrageous details but he really was
hurting people all the while what really
matters however is how others around him
react according to author Bret Easton
Ellis who pens the novel upon which the
film was based American Psycho is meant
to be a statement of male hedonism in
the 80s Wall Street circuit the whole
reason Bateman gets away with the murder
of Paul Allen is that everyone in
Patrick's professional circle is so
self-absorbed that they can't even keep
each other's identities straight their
attention is firmly focused on acquiring
material wealth and their biggest
problems revolve around getting dinner
reservations at the fanciest restaurant
in town even the owners of
Department are willing to dispose of a
serial killers evidence to ensure
maximum profit in the end there are no
redeeming qualities about Bateman or
anyone he knows for that matter and even
when he tries to come clean about what
he's done the people around him are too
wrapped up in their own interests to
care but even after admitting that there
is no catharsis my punishment continues
to elude me and I gain no deeper
knowledge of myself thanks for watching
click the loop icon to subscribe to our
youtube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]